Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to
do at the Foundation: Dr. Bright!
No more mocking SCP-008's victims!
Just because they're zombies doesn't mean
it's okay to bully them.
Playing the Michael Jackson song "Thriller"
in the presence of SCP-008 victims is strictly
prohibited.
It is also not acceptable to try and simulate
video games using victims of SCP-008.
This includes, but is not limited to, letting
them out of captivity and punching them in
order to "simulate minecraft" (couldn't you
just dig for precious minerals instead?) and
pushing agents in front of SCP-008 victims
in order to "simulate Resident Evil."
Dr. Bright is no longer allowed within 50
feet of any victims of SCP-008.